-Our next guest is
an Oscar-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning producer
behind movies
such as "The Purge,"
"Us," and "Get Out."
His annual event, BlumFest,
featuring conversations with
Blumhouse filmmakers and actors,
is going on now.
And his latest movie,
"Halloween Kills,"
is in theaters
and streaming on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-What are you guys
doing out here?
-It's Halloween.
We went trick-or-treating.
We got a whole bag of candy.
-You guys should not be out here
right now.
Okay? It's not safe.
-Ooh, I'm so scared.
-Are you guys alone?
Where are your parents?
-No.
-No, we're waiting
for our friend.
-And, like, there's a creepy man
in a white mask.
And he keeps like trying to play
hide and seek with us.
-Where did you see him?!
-He's just hiding behind trees.
-And he pops out like,
"peekaboo."
I mean, we're not
three years old.
Come on, man!
-Oh, look, there he is.
-Oh, hello!
[ Laughter ]
-Is that Dennis' mask?
-Run! Go home now!
-Please welcome to the show
Jason Blum, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, buddy.
It's so great to have you here.
-Well, it's --
I'm very excited to be here.
Very excited. This is amazing.
I've been dying
to get on this show.
-Well, this is big.
This is big for both of us.
-This is big.
-Congratulations.
This movie's doing great.
You obviously have been in
the horror business for a while.
I would imagine when you have
something like "Halloween,"
that people have
a relationship with,
you're making a sequel to it,
how much do you have to come up
with new and fascinating, and
dare I say, fun ways for people
to get murdered?
-Well, you have to --
I mean, it's a big --
We have a science lab.
We have to do
all these different things.
No, Danny McBride
and David Gordon Green
came up with these crazy ideas.
Someone gets -- One of the most
wild kills we've ever had
in a movie is they take
a fluorescent light bulb,
break it in half
and stab someone in the armpit.
-Yeah.
-And that was pretty amazing.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know.
-When they call you up
and tell you that,
are you just like mwah?
-I'm like, "Yes! Yes!"
And then they have to -- You
know, people count the kills.
They're like,
"33 kills in this movie."
There will be 47 kills
in the next movie
or something, I don't know.
-Was Halloween always
a big deal to you?
-The holiday of Halloween.
The movie not till I was older.
But the holiday of Halloween
was a big --
My mother and I loved Halloween.
My mother and I would start
doing our costumes in August.
And I was a dinosaur once.
I was the Abominable Snowman.
Halloween was a huge, huge event
in our household.
People always say, "Did you love
horror movies as a kid?"
Actually, I didn't.
I loved all kinds of movies.
But I was a very odd child.
-Okay.
-And although this is
not Halloween-related,
one of the things that I did
when I was very young is
I collected my fingernails.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-That is -- That is very odd.
[ Laughter ]
-It was very strange.
And somehow I think
this was a --
-You would clip them
and save them?
-They were a part of my body.
And I would --
-I think we know.
You can jump ahead.
We know what fingernails are.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, yes. My mistake.
I'm very nervous.
-You're starting way --
-Yeah, too early.
Starting too early. Okay, yeah.
No, but I felt
they were part of me
and I didn't want to
let them go.
So I put them in a little
plastic box, which I still have.
Now, one time --
-Wait.
-Hold on. It gets worse.
[ Laughter ]
One time, I actually -- This is
part of what was in the box.
One time I grabbed a couple of
my mother's fingernails.
[ Audience groans ]
So, in this box, there are
a bunch of tiny fingernails
from a little boy
and about eight colored
fingernails from my mother,
sitting in this box.
This box has been with me
since I was five years old.
I brought it to all the
different places that I lived.
And I very -- I thought,
astutely, hid this box
under my sink in my bathroom.
-Okay.
-My wife, Lauren Blum,
used to be my fiancée
before she was my wife, before
that, she was my girlfriend.
When she was my girlfriend --
-We all know how that works.
-Got it. Okay, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, thank you. Got it.
She found the fingernails.
-No!
-Yes. And I still married her.
That's how I knew
she was right for me.
-Right.
-Yes.
-I think I should stress
she still married you.
-That's what I meant!
That's what I meant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You were like,
"I'm still going to marry you
even though you snoop around!"
[ Laughter ]
"You go where you're not
supposed to go, Lauren."
-Correct.
[ Laughter ]
-One of my favorite things
when I first met you is,
obviously -- and I should note,
I think the first movie
that sort of brought Blumhouse
to prominence was
"Paranormal Activity."
-Correct.
-So, this is a movie that
everybody had sort of passed on.
What was it that you saw in it
that you thought,
"Oh, this is -- I actually think
an audience will love this"?
Which obviously
they ended up doing.
-A long time ago
I worked for a company
and I passed on
"The Blair Witch Project."
-Wow.
-And I never -- I never --
You know, I was always punished
for passing on that movie.
Everyone made fun.
Found footage, da-da-da.
And "Paranormal Activity,"
when it first came out,
was about 10 years
after "Blair Witch."
So that experience
was relatively new.
And I just saw it and then I
screened it with an audience.
And anyone could have told you,
if they bothered to watch it
with an audience,
the movie was going to work.
But everyone had seen it on DVD
or on cassette and passed.
It was going to home-video land,
and I said to the director,
"I really think I can get this
into a movie theater.
I passed on 'Blair Witch.'
I see the same thing here."
It took three years to do,
but it really was
the birth of our company.
So I'm very -- very --
It's a very beloved movie to me.
-And you had a dream that
if you made money on a movie,
you would get the car
that you'd always dreamed of
having to go to work in.
-Correct.
-And I'm going to show
everybody.
I want everybody to imagine what
a big Hollywood producer wanted.
-This was my dream.
-And now I'm gonna show
everybody what it is.
[ Laughter ]
I should note it says "Blumhouse
Electric" on the side of it.
-And here, I don't know
if you can see,
it says
"residential and commercial."
[ Laughter ]
-But now, you -- This is
actually a functional van.
And the reason
you wanted a van --
-So, I've always been --
I've always lived in Los Angeles
but had been trying to move back
to New York.
It's only been about 22 years.
I'm still doing it.
And I can't -- One of the things
I don't like
about Los Angeles
is the traffic.
And it's such a waste of time.
I'm a very, very
efficient person.
So I said if I ever
have a hit movie,
I'm going to get a minivan,
hence the Chevy Astro,
which is a very unusual minivan
'cause almost no minivans
have a flat back.
They always have bumps
for the axle.
The reason that handymen
always drive Chevy Astros
is because the bottom is flat.
I bought a minivan -- I bought
a used Chevy Astro for 10 grand
and I paid a stereo guy $25,000.
He ripped out the back.
He put in a comfy chair,
a computer, a printer,
when you used to have to
print boarding passes.
I used to print boarding passes
in that.
[ Laughter ]
I still have a van.
It's a little more upgraded
from that,
but it's my efficient way
to tackle
and never think about
Los Angeles traffic.
-It's really nice
that a kid creepy enough
to save fingernails ended up
in a white van.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jason Blum, everybody.
"Halloween Kills"
is in theaters now.
For more info on BlumFest 2021,
go to blumhouse.com.